i got some bad [ __ ] news a lot of
people really confused out here there is
no [ __ ] equation in this pursuit of
happiness and success that you're
looking for that doesn't require hard
work which is why i want people to kind
of build their money making and
happiness making around [ __ ] they love i
cannot believe the addiction with
excuses blame blaming your parents
blaming the system how about blaming
yourself i'm realizing that you have not
put in the work
to make a perspective shift and see the
truth as it is there's no [ __ ]
equation of achieving happiness and
success without putting in the work
mentally people love a good system a
good scheme a good quick don't want to
[ __ ] work don't like it i get it i
got these in school i didn't want to
work hated that [ __ ]
so i i know those feelings i know that
energy school ends at 18 for most people
life's another eight years
you better figure out something that you
actually [ __ ] like so that you can
put in the hours to get it done